do you think some people are destined to  be single are people supposed to be in  relationships what i don't like about  the cultural thing of you know you're  more successful if you're in a  relationship is that i deal with people  every day who become instantly more  successful the moment they leave a  relationship because they shouldn't be  in that relationship it's toxic it's  abusive they settled for something  that's far less than they deserve and so  success to me is leaving it's not  staying but when we get constantly  indoctrinated with this idea that being  in a relationship or having a  stereotypical path in life is success we  start to make really bad decisions